speaking for myself from a kenya  our trust has been shattered  and i am quite happy from water to hear  the the words from the representative of  the eu saying this  the major emitters bear the greatest  responsibility  it is not just it is not fair  and it cannot be fair  that 20 countries  that control 80 percent of the global  gdp contribute 80 percent  of the global  greenhouse emissions they have the means  they have the aware with all they are  the ones that are pushing us rightly  about um  more ambition in terms of mitigation  because that's how they interpret  ambition  they must take  their responsibility and i think one of  the recommendations that need to come  and decisions here is those who the  major emitters must  resubmit  resubmit to the ntc's by before cop 27  align them  um  to provide  align them with with 1.1.05